It’s been 10 years since the original MacBook
Air was released, and the design hasn’t
changed a single time, until now.
Apple’s new 2018 MacBook Air has been completely
redesigned to look more like their 12” MacBook,
and it all looks great, except for a few problems
that are keeping me from ordering one right
this second.
People bought the MacBook Air because it was
the cheapest way to get a reliable Apple laptop,
along with the fact that it’s thin, light,
it’s loaded with ports and it’s got great
battery life.
The biggest problem with the 2018 MacBook
Air is that it now costs $200 more, making
it only $100 cheaper than the 12” MacBook
and 13” MacBook Pro.
Now while I agree that the MacBook Air is
better than the 12” MacBook in basically
every way except being a little thicker and
weight a little bit more, the 13” MacBook
Pro has a few pretty big advantages which
I’ll talk about in a minute.
Apple really should have priced this at $1099
maximum, making the price gap $200 instead.
Onto the second problem, there are now only
2 Thunderbolt 3 ports instead of the variety
of ports that came with the old MacBook Air,
which made it so attractive to regular users.
Now, those same users have to go out and buy
adapters for all of their legacy devices,
even something as simple as using a flash
drive will require an adapter.
Yes, Thunderbolt 3 is really nice since you
can connect powerful drives and a 5K display,
but the market of regular users who just want
Apple’s cheapest MacBook don’t really
need all of that extra power like professional
users do, who are going to buying the MacBook
Pro anyways.
Overall, a lot of the MacBook Airs’ target
market is going to have issues with the USB-C
ports.
Now onto the third problem, the new MacBook
Air is still packing a dual-core processor
while the rest of the market is moving towards
quad-core processors.
Yes, it can turbo-boost up to the same clock
speed as the base 13” MacBook Pro, but the
core speed is slower, and it’s only a 7w
chip instead of 15w on the Pro.
This means that the year-old 13” MacBook
Pro will still be faster than the new MacBook
Air.
Not only that, but graphics performance is
even worse.
In fact, the MacBook Pro’s graphics is over
50% faster than on the new MacBook Air.
Of course, that’s why it’s the MacBook
Pro, but if you check B&H, it’s only $50
more than the new MacBook Air.
Apple could have easily added a 4-core processor
upgrade option to make users happy.
Yes, the target market doesn’t really need
the extra power, but the only reason I haven’t
ordered the Air already is the lack of performance,
and I’m sure I’m not alone.
For the 4th reason, even though the new MacBook
Air gets a retina display, it’s actually
worse than the 13” MacBook Pros retina display.
The Pro gets a brighter, 500 nit display which
really helps for using it outside in the daylight
or even in a really bright room.
The Pro also gets P3 wide-color gamut support,
so it’s got much better color accuracy compared
to the Air.
This is yet another reason to choose the Pro
over the Air, and you only have to pay $50
more.
For the 5th and final problem, the new MacBook
Air is still using Bluetooth 4.2 technology.
Basically every single 2018 Apple device except
for the budget iPad has now moved on to Bluetooth
5, including all of the new iPhones, the HomePod,
the Apple TV 4K, the Mac Mini, the MacBook
Pros and the new iPad Pro.
Since everything else is moving forward with
Bluetooth 5.0, it sucks that Apple decided
to keep the MacBook Air at 4.2, but it’s
not as big of an issue as everything else,
since there aren’t that many Bluetooth 5
devices yet.